hello everyone
uh today we're going to go over the
genome sequencing of cannabis sativa and
a few other medicinal fungi
um that are becoming increasingly
relevant to the dispensary markets
um we'll first we'll first touch on
cannabis that's a harder genome to
sequence than
the fungi that we're going to hit later
on but much of the interest in
sequencing
the cannabis genome is also to
understand fungi interactions we want to
understand the fungi that
reduce the plant's yield and and create
pathogenic risk for the for
the customers and also under the fungi
that might be
beneficial to the plants yield uh that
might assist in nitrogen fixation or
colonizing the rhizosphere so uh
cannabis is one of these plants that's
uh highly polymorphic i usually
sniff every 50 bases um 64
80 it's about an 850 megabase genome
uh diploid 10 chromosomes and there's an
xy sex system involved
so we set out doing this with clr a few
years ago and recently topped it off
with hifi sequencing
uh and this has been uh tremendously
helpful because many of the genes
involved
in the chemical synthesis of the
cannabinoids are in copy number flux in
the genome and they're buried in these
ltr forests this multi-megabase
about 30 kb unit ltr force that
is very challenging to um to read with
short reads in fact we spent a decade
playing around
with short reads on illumina trying to
assess this genome
and it's very difficult to do uh and
thoroughly capture all the cannabinoids
in these genes and so we're going to
walk you through some of that
today um this of course started uh
in our interest to understand powdery
mildew resistance
powdery mildew is a fungi that grows on
the surface of the plant and can obscure
the photosynthesis
photosynthesis it can also affect the
yield of the plant and weaken its immune
system
there are plants that are known to be
powdery mildew resistant you can see a
picture of this
on the top and bottom panels here the
top panel leaves you can see these white
colonies that begin to form
and on the right you can see that
eventually graduates into a very snowy
looking leaf that obscures
some of the photosynthetic yield but
these can coexist next to plants that
are completely resistant and don't show
any signs despite
there being close contact with these
plants so this is um
this got us thinking what's involved in
this there are some
suggestions as to what might be involved
in this by studying hops the
field has been looking at powdery mildew
resistance for some time
and so we began by sequencing these
genomes and a lot of this data is
actually public now
in the um and bioarchive and other
places so i'm going to quickly skim
through some of the sequencing
statistics so we can spend
some time on the pathways but um there's
a there's a bioarchive print of ours
that is uh that's out that has these
assemblies
uh including many clr assemblies
and those mapped with another 40 genomes
of illumina data
so uh we've we've since decorated uh the
annotations of these genomes with lots
of
other hemp and cannabis lines uh
sequenced with shorter reads and those
shorter reads are much more useful
when you have a reference that sorts out
all these copy number changes
there's been a great review on many of
the genomes that are public i encourage
people
to go see in the upper right here this
recent advances in cannabis
sativa genomics research this
her gobin work uh has thoroughly gone
over the different uh busco scores and
n50s and that's a really good summary of
what's going on in the field
um so the assemblies that we got from
the clr process out of pac bio a few
years ago
gave us wonderful assembly some of the
best assemblies uh they've ever been
published
um came off of these things it's largely
a function of
of us trying to tackle this system later
than other groups other groups started
on this when the reed lengths
were in the 5kb range and we were
fortunate to come late
uh and and apply you know 20 to 30 kb
clr reads on this
uh so this gave us n50s that were north
of a megabase uh
some as high as 3.4 megabases um we
didn't do a trio and this trio is
actually has
parents that are siblings so they're
somewhat related
you can see the respective assemblies
that uh have resulted the male genomes
are much larger because the y chromosome
is in fact the largest chromosome in the
genome somewhere
uh it's probably around 85 to 90
megabases um
on top of that you can see we did some
different things um
deduplicating this data and i say
de-duplicating is after you perform an
assembly like this there are multiple
there could be multiple hapletigs that
are
diverged enough such that they end up as
unique contigs as opposed to a collapsed
half-life version of the assembly this
is a
process known as purge hapletigs that
help separate these out well
we did that on the father and the
daughter i'm sorry uh we didn't do that
in the father and daughter and you can
see there's a much higher duplication
rate in those genomes and the genomes a
little bit elevated in size as a result
of this
in the mother we did go about trying to
de-duplicate the data
using purge haplotakes and that does
bring the duplicated uh busco scores
down quite a bit but you can see we also
lose some of the completeness in the
process so
the process of untangling and unzipping
this genome is still
an ongoing effort to do it in such a way
where you don't
suffer any loss in the busco genes so
um to try to address this problem we
circled back and resequenced the mother
with hifi
and that came out to a 5.2 megabase
assembly much better assembly
and there's some actually really
interesting features in this assembly
and that we can see the telomeres now
very clearly which we couldn't see
before
those things i think have tangled up in
the clr assemblies um
and yes we can get the busco scores up
to 97.4 if we don't do any deduplication
of the data but if you do any duplic
the duplication at least that we tried
with utilizing the assemblers at hand
did
leave us with some loss of some busco
genes the process so
you know at the moment we're using a
collage of some of these genomes where
we have the mother's genome and we tack
on the y chromosome to it
um and uh we're leaving the uh the hi-fi
assembly
at the moment is still being annotated
uh most of the annotations are done on
the clr assemblies but
nevertheless it's a good composite set
of data that we can use to begin to
assemble a pan genome
speaking of pan genomes uh we did take
uh high canoe
and assemble these as well um and we're
able to compare those high canoe
and high canoe you feed it hifi data uh
we're able to compare those to the clr
assemblies and we get very good
linearity between
um the jamaican lion um genome over here
where we have tacked on the y and you
can see some of the artifacts of the
there's a pseudo-autozoomal region on
the on the y that is very similar to the
x which is what i think you're seeing up
here
and then in the um we've compared that
to the high canoe reference versus
the clr reference with the y attacked on
from the from the
um in the father uh and then you can
also see that against cs10 which is
another great assembly this in ncbi
it's done a little bit earlier than ours
so it has shorter reads and the contents
didn't
i think it's still in the 750 kb and 50
range but
it's a different cultivar that's missing
some key regions we want the reference
it is a type 3 meaning it only makes cbd
so we don't have a lot of
information on the on the thc
synthesis pathway and it's also missing
a y chromosome the largest chromosome
in the genome so uh it's a handy
reference but it's one of many in in a
pan genome process
um and then you can see the um the
daughter against the mother and the
father against the mother
and the daughter against the father here
but um the assemblies
are very congruent between one another
and um this pan genome starting to shape
it quite nicely
you can use tools like circos to map
these to one another there's cs10 on the
left and jamaican line on the right and
you can see there's um mostly
there's a lot of collinearity and
synthetic and there's a couple
differences and we're still in the
process of understanding if those
differences are in fact biologically
real
or some assembly artifacts that could be
going on between the genomes
um some of the telomeres um we were kind
of shocked that we we would find
30 40 kb telomeres popping out of this
data it's really fascinating to see
those types of repeat structures fully
resolved
and um they're very difficult to see in
the shorter read assemblies in fact
sometimes
our terminal telomeres that we have in
our assembly are occasionally i think in
chromosome 5 or mapping
internally to other references in the
cs10 reference
that may in fact be an order and
orientation problem in previous
references
because usually internal telomeric
repeats aren't that large
so there may still be some challenges
with some of the existing assemblies
that are in ncbi and we're hoping the
hi-fi data will come and clean this up
like it has on
many of the human genome references i'm
not going to spend much time on the um
microsatellites those do get cleaner
with hifi and it's very important for
the y chromosome the y chromosome
has 82 repeat content and has like three
times the um
the density of ssr so it's very
difficult to sequence very ltr rich
there has been hi-fi done these as well
um
our hi-fi data if we take that and
utilize it to try to run high c
maps against the other references they
build these nice pictures
and there's hi-fi the other folks
submitting these have also run some high
five their own and they have nice
high c contact maps as well um this is
there's another um
jl not jamaican lion which is the
reference that we're working on there's
another one
a strain named jl coming out of china
right now but just
be aware that's not the same as what
we're doing and those can often get
confused so once we had some high c
information
those short reads are oftentimes
difficult to map as i've mentioned
before and so it's always good to get a
linkage map performed which we have done
with a snip chip that we have built
uh that sequence is about 85 000 our
genotypes about 85 000 locations and
these
colored boxes that you're seeing in this
linkage map here
are areas of congruency between the uh
the linkage information and the high c
information so we've got
a really good agreement between these
two platforms we're still itemizing a
couple of the differences
but um this can be very a very helpful
tool for understanding or combination
rates in the genome
this work was done in collaboration with
organ cbd and europeans
this is uh the paper that i mentioned
earlier that recently published from the
boateng group and it has many of the
references that are in ncbi about half
of them are generated by
medicinal genomics the chem dog line and
the l.a confidential or all those
jamaica buy-ins were done
uh in beverly mass and uh the the chem
dog and the la confidential were done
with shorter read technologies chem dog
was on illumina back in 2011
la confidential was in 2011 with 600
base pair 454.
so even back then we recognized we
needed longer reads um they just
uh we had to wait almost nine years for
them to get accurate enough um
uh with pack by offer to really make an
affordable and a large difference
um so what are some of these bar graphs
you're seeing here well
you can see the the the genomes that
have the least missing content are the
jamaican line references
right that that i think is a testimony
to the pac bio sequencing data
now there is a larger amount of
duplicated genes in these genomes
because we haven't aggressively
de-duplicated them with the exception of
the mother line here which we have
deduplicated somewhat aggressively
but our opinion on this is we would
rather have complete genomes with
duplication
than ones that are incomplete perfectly
purged
because we do not want to lose gene
content and so while a lot of these
other genomes are deemed references
this one in particular is probably the
most utilized in ncbi
it is missing many more genes than
jamaican lion they did a great job
de-duplicating it
but it does come with more fragmented
genes and more missing genes
we have been leaving those duplicated
the context in because
we think when you're mapping short read
alumina data you'd rather have the two
diverged copies present in the reference
the reads go to the right places than
trying to condense those
into a single representation or a
haploid representation it's better to
take a pan genome approach if you will
and leave some of that duplicated
content in because your reads need to
get recruited to those very similar
locations so we've gone with this
approach working off of these three
genomes primarily and i think that'll
become a little more evident when you
see what this stuff looks like with the
illumina sequencing that we're doing
i mean one thing that's very clear from
this paper is
the vast majority of the cannabinoid
synthase genes
that people are studying here are the
ones with these longer names on them and
those are jamaican lion
cannabioid synthase genes so we're
finding more of them in the jamaican
line reference and i think that's a
testimony to
the clr data and the pac bio data
actually resolving these repeat
structures discovering more of these
unique genes and not collapsing them
so we can properly map illuminated data
to them going forward
so this is this is a collection of all
the cannabinoids synthase genes they
found amongst all the genomes that were
in ncbi and there's
a large contribution of those from from
the more complete references
you can map a lot of the snip data
against this i should say the illumina
date against this and derive
snips so this is uh 58 million snips
that we found mapping the 40 aluminum
genomes against the jamaican line mother
reference
and you can see jamaican line here is in
the center where the variation
goes down quite a bit and that makes
sense because all of its siblings down
here
are also sequenced and its siblings of
course are going to be more closely
related and should have fewer snips
but as you move into the hemp lines you
can see we end up getting into the 14 to
15 million
numbers of snips per genome and that's
higher in the hemp lines than it is in
the drug type
so the the jamaican lion reference uh
seems to be more drug type than it is
um hemp even though it is a type 2 plant
it makes both cbd and thc but it makes
it's not a very long and stalky hemp
plant it's more of a fat flowering
plants that you'd expect in the drug
types
so this data actually resonates with
what we're seeing
from the phenotypes the plant and what
it's more similar to
in terms of phenotypes
okay so let's get into copy number
variation here there are lots of copy
number
variations on what we're looking at over
here on the left are all the cannabinoid
synthase genes that we have in jamaican
line genome
there's a couple other genes that are on
the same context that are coming along
for the ride in this
um and what you can see is the jamaican
lion references here are purple
which is sort of your your average
ploidy that you'd expect
and the red and blue are either
duplications or
deletions that exist in the genome so
one very obvious pattern we see here is
this
inactive thc synthase which is actually
known now known to be cannabi chromium
synthase
different cannabinoid than you hear in
the news it does have pharmaceutical
properties
but you can see that it's in fact in
copy number flux
in many of the hemp lines and it's
missing in some of the in some of the
drug type lines
now this is important because you need
to really keep track of every
cannabinoid synthase gene in the genome
if you want to breed for plants that are
compliant with the dea regulations
you can have more than .3 thc in your
crop
or your whole crop can get confiscated
and burnt down and you can lose your
farm
um so this this comes with criminal
negligence charges if you don't get this
right
so it's very important that you have
plants that don't go above 0.3
thc now that's not um you cannot
get that by just tracking thc synthase
which is a single gene way up here up
top
cbd and thc synthase are some of the
most interesting ones that we have
in the genome because they're known to
make cbd and thc however
what is now known after you clone these
genes into yeast is that they're not
pure
enzymes in that they're a little
promiscuous cbd synthase makes a 20 to 1
ratio of cbd to thc
so even if your thc synthase gene is
knocked out and you only have a cbd
synthase gene
you're not guaranteed to be clean of 0.3
thc levels all right
so um all of these other cannabinoid
synthase genes we suspect
also leak they haven't all been cloned
yet and so this is
still a bit of a hypothesis but uh they
have very high sequence identity
they're functional and some of them are
expressed so we suspect they could be
contributing to basal levels of thc
thc synthase or thj synthase activity
and
um and that can that can follow up your
compliance
so understanding the actual copy number
of these things is really important so
down here 40 genomes
here are all of the different synthase
genes
what i have down here in yellow are a
handful of other genes
that are co-deleted when this cannabic
chromium deletion
occurs this can have a chromium deletion
is actually two megabases long
and it contains some of these genes down
here so many farmers are trying to breed
to knock out this cassette because if
they knock out this cassette as one more
cassette of many thc synthase like genes
that could be leaking and if it's gone
then there's less of them they have to
worry about
however we have to pay attention to what
these genes do in the process
on the right are a handful of three
different types of genes
uh chitinases which are anti-fungal
uh tlps which is a thymitine like
protein which is a gluconase also
antifungal
opens up fungal cell walls and then mlo
which is a
loci that was uh derived from hops uh
hops
makes a mildew uh milder susceptibility
locus which is uh
of importance so um tracking the copy
number of these lettuces some very
interesting things that we're going to
touch on at the end of this
uh this is perhaps the most important
region that many people are tracking
uh for thc and cb synthase this is known
as the bt bidi allele
and it looks as if it is a copy note but
predominantly a copy number variation in
the genome
where the plants can either have a fully
functional copy
of thc synthase and lack a cbd synthase
in which case there are type 1 plants
type 1 type 2 type 3. type 2 plants make
a mixture of both like jamaican line
they make both cbd and thc and type 3
plants make only cbd
and you can see the presence or absence
of this gene dictates what's going on
now that's that's 95 maybe 99 of the
story there's some rare point mutations
we have found that can also play a role
in this picture okay so what are these
extra genes that come along for the ride
when cannabi chromium is deleted well
there's
nfp3 which is a gibberellin transporter
there's a viral defense gene there's a
pamp induced
secreted peptide there's an aquaporin
gene these are all genes are involved in
pathogen response so if you're not
careful when you
breathe for plants that have this
deleted you may take some of these out
with for the ride and you may have a
plant that's more susceptible to
pathogen problems
you'll see it's not a clean picture down
here some of the cultivars actually have
varying numbers of these things so some
some directive breeding might be in
order
the y chromosome sticks out like a sore
thumb these are males these are females
and it's pretty clear which one's
the y chromosome now that we have this
uh this is greatly aided with a lot of
the pipe bio and hifi data
um okay so what can we do with illumina
data well now that we have these regions
that are perfectly
um assembled with the pac bio data we
can now accurately map our illumina data
this is illumina coverage maps over
these regions so we have the active cbda
gene here there's absolutely nothing
there we have the thc gene
uh that we can see that's got great
coverage so it's there i've highlighted
two point mutations here that are quite
critical
in this case these two point mutations
are actually knocking out thc synthase
and there's another gene that looks a
lot like cbd synthase that we used to
confuse
these reads with these reads because the
the illumina data and the assemblies
didn't split them apart
these happen to be actually quite close
to one another so for a very long time
we were confused
thinking that thc and cbd synthase were
right next to each other
they're not there's a close neighbor
that has a deletion in it right next to
each other
but um these reads were often giving us
false signals when you can separate
these copy number events
out these things become much more clear
and you can see that these reads don't
belong there anymore they belong over
here
and that these reads are in fact not
contributing to chemotype this is a this
is a pseudo gene
here is uh can have a chromine synthase
where there's absolutely no coverage
over
over that region in this in this planet
this is what we would call a type four
plant a plant that does that only makes
the precursor which is known as
cannabidirl
it tries to make thc synthase but it it
has a dysfunctional two-point mutations
that make it non-functional so
this is a great story of understanding
copy number flux and point mutations in
order for you to properly call the
chemotypes which is why
having these these pack buyer references
is utterly critical if you want to make
use of aluminum data
we have a lot of this data up in a site
called canopedia
it houses a lot of this information
there's probably about 500 000 strains
up there now that are public for anyone
to download
and there's a blockchain registration
for these things that's helped
that's in place to help with
intellectual property rights and
breeders rights
there's a phylogenetic tree so this can
help um give you information about
what it's related to what to breed it
with um
there is a list of all of the other
plants and they're how distant they are
the distance can be very important for
plant patents plant patents are over
clonal
propagated plants so they would have to
be on top of one another to be uh
to be eligible uh for being identical
according to a plant patent
plant utility patents and pvps are quite
different those are more diverged plants
and there's probably less relevance for
those the data set however these tools
can be used
as a defensive prior art tool to
demonstrate a born on date of the
particular strain so that you don't get
uh you know submarine by a patent that
comes out on your strain later
uh we to help facilitate this we scan
this against as much public data as we
get our hands on
to also look if there's any overlapping
regions with our sequencing panel
and with um with their data so that we
can call whether it's truly unique
and then there's some blockchain
information here that just hashes and
stashes the data now we don't put all
the sequence data in the blockchain it
doesn't fit
but we do put a hash of the vcf file in
there that can give you a
a proof or a born on date that's
independent of our company if we
disappear
that still sits in a distributed ledger
that you can access with your
information
um okay so this just gives you a look at
what these things uh what the different
types of plants look like with alumina
data
and you can see up here this is a type 1
plant which makes all thc
we have no cbd gene we have a thc gene
and it's an active partner
type 2 plants have all three here type
three plants that only make cbd
have a cbd gene here uh nothing no
coverage over thc and no coverage
oversea
over um the cbd gene and then the type
four plants don't have any of these
things
sometimes you can have an active thc
gene with point mutations however
that we have found but um generally the
trend we see is that all three of them
are knocked out
so we went to build the snip chip as i
mentioned earlier to do that genetic map
and that snip chip we were somewhat
doubting we'd be able to resolve this
complexity with a snip chip
and so what we did is we hyper tiled
these regions with lots of assays
so we could have a better look at this
data the y chromosome is very easy when
you tile the y chromosome we put over we
put 3.3
000 markers across the y chromosome and
what you're seeing is that
the females don't have any signal on
these markers and the males do have
signals on these markers
and your sample of interest here is in
gray and you can see that's superimposed
on top of all of these markers uh
behaving
a few in the middle here that don't
behave and that could be some some you
know differences between the y
chromosome but most of the y chromosomes
are in fact
lit up that tells us it's a male over
here
it shows you what a female is actually
going to look like when all of the
signal is lagging like this this is
negative in the rfe scale we actually
have
we know that this is in fact a female
all right so that's easy that's shooting
fish in a barrel big chromosome lots of
markers what do we do with thg synthase
this is a 2kb
gene or under 1.6 kb gene but we tiled
all around it
and you can see what happens when it's
thc positive
is you end up with signal on top of the
line and when it's negative you have
signal below the line and that's how we
discern whether thc synthase gene is
present
and the trend follows with cbc and cbd
as well
we can we can clearly see things that
are cbd negative and cbd positive
uh likewise with cdc so the snip chip is
actually working quite well
for something we didn't expect to get
out of it um there's a lot of other
things we did expect to get out of it we
threw
on uh 12 000 markers that are
that are that are within genes that have
sniff effect scores of five
uh so they're very damaging mutations
amongst all of these genes
um and then we also threw in uh 3.3 000
across the y
we hyper tile those genes that i just
went over
but we also put some genes into the
precursors the things that make the
cannabis rl that make the livital and
make the gbp those things are all the
precursors and the fuel needed to make
these cannabinoids
and they're they're they're controlled
by some of these parental transferases
and tks genes and olivitolic acid
cyclase genes so those are covered
a lot of the terpene synthase genes that
are described in these papers are
covered
the canned flavon genes uh we we threw
in there as well and some of these
pathogen response genes that we're going
to talk
talk about we do have six and a half
thousand markers that are consistent
with the sequencing assay that we're
using on illumina so you can intersect
the data from the chip with the data
from
the string seek sure select panel that
we have
so um there's a lot of content on here
that's um that's quite handy
and it can be very helpful for running
breeding
um now we annotated a lot of this with
isoseq data which was really
remarkable how well that worked the isoc
gave us incredibly
you know beautiful high quality long
reads that allowed us to annotate the
intron exon boundaries quite nicely
i don't have a lot of time to go into
this other than to point out that's the
hottest genes that we have in the genome
is this kitenase gene so we cloned that
gene and we cloned a tlp as well a
thomatine like protein and we started a
point deploying these in beta-glucanased
assays
in a man an assay described by misra
which is more of an analog approach
where you put the enzyme on wattman
paper
and see if you can get the morphology of
the colony to change it all based on
differing amounts of enzyme in fact we
can see that with penicillium
chrysogen over here we can see some
impact of it with fusarium as well
and this is a nice visual cue but it's
hard to quantitate and so we did
eventually
convert this assay into a quantitative
pcr assay
where you can put these cloned enzymes
that are expressed in e coli purified
with a his tag and then drop them into
the broth at various concentrations
and compare how well various uh
pathogens
actually grow in these broths so we in
this case we put an s for jealous niger
we've tried this with a variety of other
cannabis pathogens and we do see several
ct
offsets with the organisms that are
grown
in the presence of these enzymes versus
the controls
so it's a sign that the enzymes are
functional coming out of e coli and they
in fact make an offset in in
aspergillus growth so um this is
consistent with these plants being
powdered milder resistant
so now what we're doing is we're taking
that enzyme and using it in our dna
preps we we have a total yeast and mold
test out there
that for a long time has been compared
to plating but plating only grows things
that are
viable pcr gets everything however your
pcr needs to be able to lyse everything
and i don't think we are adequately
lysing everything in the past because we
weren't aware of these
kitinases and so we've been taking these
deploying them into our lysis buffers
in the pcr front and getting much better
results
this is just an example of the type of
micro
diversity that you find on a cannabis
flower and naturally we have been taking
each one of these independently
growing them out sequencing their
genomes to understand what they are and
ensuring that our actual dna prep can
now lice open
all of these with um this new enzyme
approach and we're putting this through
an aoec
review at the moment for uh tests to be
in the marketplace so
a lot you can learn with genomics when
you have good references because
sometimes when the references are really
fragmented
it's very hard to separate out some of
the microbial content from the cannabis
genome because they share some
information
and some homologies in certain regions
of the genome and now that we have a
very good reference it's much easier
to tease some of this metagenomic stuff
out
um important for a lot of the microbes
that don't culture in fact so
the other things that don't culture are
the viruses all right and so
viruses are can have a huge impact on
the grow they they tend to not emerge
until you're in flowering so you can
spend eight weeks growing your crop
under really expensive lights and then
the viruses show up when you when you
flip the light
the light cycle they start to express in
flowering and then they destroy your
crop at the 11th hour which is really
painful
so there's a couple that have been
described with sequence information
there is hops
latent vibroid which is not a virus but
a vibroid no shell on that thing no
capsid
there's lettuce chlorosis virus which
does have a capsid um
and these are rna viruses and there's
cannabis cryptic virus this one doesn't
have much of a phenotype yet so that's
why it's called cryptic
but these other two do have a phenotype
and the phenotype you can see in the
right here is they really destroy growth
a lot of chlorotic tissue but
fortunately
we can sift these now from the genome
having a really good reference
we can design pcr assays that don't
trigger off the reference
and are very specific to the actual
virus
that gives us nice quantitative pcr
results where we can screen
mother plants before they get cloned out
and know which ones have viruses and
which ones don't
this is another picture of what happens
to your crop late stages all of the fan
leaves start to deteriorate and
the yield craters as a result so there's
a lot of tools here
that we can now work with we've got
folks that are tissue culturing
jamaican lions so this can become a
resource for people in massachusetts it
can't ship over state lines yet
that may change with federal
legalization we have
85 k snip arrays um that we can use and
then there are these like mini exomes
that we use with agilent that are
right now the panel is about five
megabytes i'm sorry it's ten megabases
in size
previous ones with three megabases we're
just upgrading that now but all of this
data is now stuffed into koji now that
so you can surf through this and you can
take your own private data
and load it into koji against a lot of
other public data that i will
share with you a few slides forward so
what else can be done with these types
of data sets well this was a pilot
project that we did with oregon cbd
where they took uh the snip chip and ran
it on a couple hundred samples
and in their first study there they
found two markers they could convert
into pcr asses or quite predictive of
what they're looking for they were
looking for an autoflower allele which
is an allele
that enables you to get one more growth
cycle in when they're shorter
in the shorter days in the winter time
in the northern hemisphere and this
autoflower allele stuck out like a sore
thumb on their first association study
and then they also found one for cbdv
which is a
a shorter version of the cannabinoid
that's uh that is not
accounted for in the thc numbers so if
you want to breed for plants that are
more compliant you want to breed for
thcv because it doesn't count against
you
with the point three percent um thc and
that does have some pharmaceutical
or um those are some properties it's not
as psychoactive as thc so it's not on
the dea's radar
but it does have some interesting
properties when it comes to
weight loss and so there's a lot of
interest in that cannabinoid for
reducing people's
desire to eat this is what happens to
grow once you have molecular markers in
the right you have to grow things out
for six weeks or more
to figure out what genotype your plan is
or what
what phenotype it's expressing once you
have the genotype
that tracks with that qtl uh you can
then track them with qpcr on two tables
the size as opposed to a whole hallway
here so this has really been um a great
success story over at
oregon cbd they've got this now up and
running
and uh we were quite surprised this
happened and just dropped out of the
first
um test that we ran the first study of a
couple hundred sniff ships went into
this
okay so there's over four terabases of
sequence that's now mapped
as as bam files that you can download um
in koji so these are mapped to the
jamaican line mother
and uh there's now 50 whole genomes up
there that you can download that are up
and around 50x coverage and there's
another 50 strain seeks in there that
people can download
and we've put in every other public form
of data we can find there's mass spec
data that's been supplied by the
the oarsborn laboratory and um there is
a lot of rna iso seek data that we've
contributed as well so
like i said before you can take your
privately sequenced data
map it against this public data that's
there in a private manner now you don't
have to necessarily put your data public
to utilize this tool this is a tool
meant for anyone to utilize
whether they have their data public or
private the iso seek data is very
helpful to understand the splice
junctions as well
okay so what other fungi are of interest
to us
we've been talking about aspergillus a
lot of these things that harm the plant
but there's another medicinal fungi
that's being legalized in a variety of
jurisdictions oakland berkeley
i think denver legalized this cambridge
somerville
has decriminalized this i'm sorry
there's also been
the whole state of oregon has
decriminalized this as well
and we wouldn't do this if we're just
for fun because there is uh in fact
breakthrough fda has cla has clarified
some of these compounds as breakthrough
therapies for depression
uh and terminal cancer depression is one
area that johns hopkins is looking at so
um this pathway is um quite compact and
much easier to read in this genome this
genome is only 46 megabases so
we did sequence this in 2016 with
illumina and it ended up
very fragmented as expected recently
some other groups
have jumped on this and uh even broken
down the entire pathway
uh and there's some great papers out
there from the spencer torrens lab
from the reynolds laboratory i think
there's a variety of others that have
contributed to the
the horizontal gene transfer of this
data so i apologize for not having this
this figure properly referenced this
comes from their work not ours
um but this is uh an important pathway
that involves a handful of genes
um that makes a diversity of compounds
everyone's
probably familiar with psilocybin which
is the phosphorylated version of this
compound
but celosin is missing that phosphate
group
and you can even find baocystine and
origination in here which
have varying degrees of methyl groups on
those r's and
this r group here and that changes the
psychoactivity of the compound and some
of the pharmaceutical properties of the
compound so
they are all different branch points in
this pathway so understanding each of
these genes
is really critical and this was actually
decoded by groups prior to us who
figured out that these cassettes look
like they're horizontally
moved around in many fungi and it's not
just cytoside cubensis who makes these
compounds but you can find it in
cyanosense and a variety of other
stylocybe or philosophy
genuses out there so so we we sequenced
one down here i think you'll find
cyanosins compared
to the hifi reference that we generated
from uh
a strain that's embarrassingly known as
penis envy um
this is a uh a a strain that's known to
make twice the amount of uh
psilocybin um there is also a couple of
others that we've put into ncbi known as
golden teacher and b
plus so they have just as creative names
as you find in the cannabis industry
for these strains but they are all quite
different
and you can see the some of the scatter
plots down here between
uh the hi-fi reference and what's in the
jgi database
uh and uh what we've sequenced before
and even more distant lines like
cyanosense down here
that are um that have the the genomes a
little bit more broken up
but this cassette here is what's
important uh and it does vary a little
bit um going
species to species um but just to give
you some color as to what these look
like if you were to assemble this with
alumina you get the assembly graph here
on the right which is quite a knot
and when you do this with hi-fi it turns
into almost a picture-perfect uh
set of long contacts so the n50s on here
are much better on the hi-fi set we're
we're up at 3.3 megabase and 50s it's
only in like 32 contigs
compared to the thousands of contents
that we're getting before and the n50s
down here without the scaffolds are
really at like 44 kb
uh the busco scores are a little bit
better but this is actually pretty good
with aluminum alone actually 96.9
percent is uh
is remarkable uh from aluminum assembly
but it does get more complete as you
move to
hifi data and of course managing only
30 32 with 33 contents is preferred
so this is what you can see when you
begin to resolve these regions
is you can see the the pmb reference
that we have up here
actually has um a very different region
compared to the other uh the other
genomes this here is the
n-methyltransferase gene this is the
gene that's involved in putting some
methyl groups in the molecule which
aids in its psychoactivity and there is
a very subtle
change in the last exon of this gene
in the reference genome and all of the
other alumina data mapped to it has a
4.6 kb
deletion here and there's an insertion
in the reference
we don't know what this means
biologically other than is right in the
pathway and
it may be playing a role in why there's
a higher psilocybin expression
in um that we see inside of the
reference genome so
this is uh an interesting um artifact
and we're also tracking all of the the
variants that we're finding inside these
genes
and the copy number because we do think
there's some unique genes that are
actually in the reference genome that
don't seem to be in
uh some of the other aluminum generated
assemblies
so i want to thank a lot of people
involved in this uh it took a lot of
work we've got uh blockchain experts
that are that are helping out and
managing the uh
the the the data notarization that we
have in canapedia there's a lot of help
that was
uh from uh pac bio on this oregon cbd
should be on this sheet as well they
helped do the hifi sequencing for
um for the cubensis genome uh new
england biolabs has been very
instrumental getting a lot of those 40
genomes done phase genomics was helpful
for for pinning together some of those
high c maps
uh we've worked closely with agilent a
lot of the share select work
um we have we didn't touch on the today
but we have been doing work with eiken
chemical and arbor
and of course eurofins has been helping
us with the with the um the snip chips
um so it does in fact uh take a village
and uh
if they're not mentioned on here uh i
want to particularly point out
seth crawford's work um that went into
this and aaron tripp who were up at
oregon cbd
uh who helped us with the um not only
the snip chip evaluation but also the um
the cubensis
reference building so um and with that i
will leave it for questions thank you